I'll be the spark if you'll be the flame
Start a reaction that can't be contained
Balance your pH by sharing my base
I'll be your star if you'll be my space
'Cause there is no distance that I wouldn't go
Through space-time and wormholes my matter would flow, to the edge of the universe
I'll be your G if you will be C or I can be A if you will be T
If there's a mutation I'll fix every base
Working as your zinc finger nuclease
Just like an atom
Don't rip us apart
Unless you want a big BOOM!
In my heart
We can take it fast, or really slow
But we can't know, with certainty, where we'll go
If at first we don't succeed, we'll try two more times
So our failure's a statistically significant try
Like an equation, it all works out
If we balance the sides there's no need to doubt
This is your science love song
A place to start our chemical bond
A research endeavour
We can write the conclusion together
Just like the moview I'd steal your heart
But then you'd die... so I won't do that
If we broke up, I'd be no more
I'd give up H20 for H2SO4
Take away gravity, I'd still fall for you
Share my last electron in a covalent bond for two
'Cause you're like that angle, Acute and you're smart
Your labcoat and goggles go straight to my heart
Except that's a lie, cause the heart doesn't feel
When it comes to love the brain seals the deal
This is your science love song
A place to start our chemical bond
A research endeavour
We can write the conclusion
-conclusion together
With twenty annotations and bibliography
'Cause you matter to me
Hey thanks for watching
If you liked the song be sure to check it our on iTunes and Bandcamp
You can also follow us on Instagram and Twitter with the links in the description below
And make sure that you subscribe to AsapScience for more weekly science videos.
We'll see you next week
[Whispers] Peace!